Village his whole life he says the
streets here are quieter than they used
to be
most young people have moved to Beijing
65 kilometers away
there are more and more old people now
too many old people in this Village
although five passed away recently due
to the covet they were over 80 years old
the situation is similar in many parts
of China where increasingly deaths are
outstripping births the population
shrunk about 850 000 people in 2022
it's the first decline since 1961 a year
of Great Famine in China
economists say strict coronavirus
measures imposed until late last year
accelerated a looming demographic crisis
the pandemic has been the biggest the
constraint for people's family planning
in the past three years and a lot of
Chinese people believe that the
vaccination would be bad for fertility
so many families have been postponing
and when it comes to the economic
pressure it was an even bigger problem
for urban residents
the government abandoned its one child
policy in 2016 and now allows families
to have up to three children but many
are unwilling citing soaring housing
prices and education fees meanwhile
China's Workforce a key driver of
economic growth is rapidly aging
analysts predict the elderly will make
up one-third of the population by 2050.
in by Jawan most of the residents are
retired the cost of living in villages
like this is far less than the bigger
cities but locals tell us the problem is
being able to find a stable income many
of the young people who were born here
have been forced to leave in order to
secure a job
Chun Ling says he understands he and his
wife have no children but still struggle
to make ends meet
for many here living day to day having
to support a large family has little
appeal
Katrina you Al Jazeera by Jawan Shanghai
County China